Pascal Godefroit, ce que l'on voit ici est le moulage d'un Microraptor ?
Oui, en fait, c'est le moulage probablement d'une nouvelle espèce de Microraptor
qui est actuellement en cours d'étude, en collaboration avec des collègues chinois
Ce spécimen est vraiment exceptionnel parce qu'on peut vraiment voir les traces
des plumes et des ailes chez ce Microraptor.
Vous pouvez voir, au niveau des bras, la présence de longues plumes
marquant de longues ailes, un petit peu commes les oiseaux actuels.
Mais si vous regardez autour des pattes arrières
vous pouvez voir, également, de longues plumes
donc probablement, ce specimen avait 4 ailes, une sorte de biplan.
Avec des griffes, aussi, à l'extrémité des membres antérieurs et postérieurs.
Oui, ses griffes lui permettaient, probablement, de grimper aux arbres
et on peut imaginer que cet animal
pouvait planer d'arbre en arbre,
ou du sommet d'un arbre vers le sol,
éventuellement pour attraper des proies ou pour échapper à de gros prédateurs.
Les Microraptors sont des très proches cousins du fameux Velociraptors de Steven Spielberg.
On imaginait que les Velociraptors étaient recouverts d'écailles
comme un crocodile, comme un lézard,
mais c'est grâce aux découvertes qui ont été faites dans le Liaoning,
on sait , à l'heure actuelle, que, non seulement,
ces animaux étaient recouverts de plumes mais, en plus,
ils avaient 4 ailes. Donc l'image, que l'on s'est faite des raptors à partir des films de Spielberg,
est, à l'heure actuelle, complètement dépassée, complètement erronée.
Ce que l'on voit ici, c'est le moulage d'un autre dinosaure à plumes, volant.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on appelle un Anchiornis
Les Anchiornis sont nettement plus anciens, plus vieux que les Microraptors.
Les Microraptors datent de 125 millions d'années,
les Anchiornis datent de 160 millions d'années.
Anchiornis a été décrit en 2009,
et lors de sa description, on l'a indentifié comme étant un dinosaure à plumes.
Nous avons réétudié ces animaux et nous pensons
que les Anchiornis seraient plutôt des oiseaux très primitifs,
des oiseaux plus primitifs que l'Archæopteryx.
Et ce dinosaure planait, lui aussi ?
Oui, dans tous les cas, on peut voir, également, sur ce specimen
la présence de 4 ailes :
des ailes au niveau des pattes avant comme ici
mais également au niveau des pattes arrières.
Donc, ils pouvaient planer probablement grâce à 4 ailes,
un petit peu comme le Microraptor.
Donc, tout ça, qu'est-ce que ça signifie ?
Au cours de l'évolution des vols
on est passé, probablement, d'un stade 4 ailes primitif,
vers un stade 2 ailes plus élaboré que l'on retrouve chez les oiseaux plus évolués.